thanks to the organizers Nikhil and Leon
and also thanks to the organizers of the
entire program in great sofa so this
talk is about keeping exchange markets
and surprisingly this is the first talk
on kidney exchange so I'm gonna have to
start giving you some background and
kidney exchange I'll be very brief
because I'm guessing most of you already
and once I'm done with that and I will
talk about our main research question
which is concerned with the following
which is concerned with basically the
question of can we improve the
efficiency of kidney exchange markets by
thickening the market and I'll be more
precise what I mean by thickening once
we actually get so let's start oh and
what I'm gonna tell you is basically
based on three papers
I will mainly focus on this more recent
one but I will also touch upon the
results from the first so let's start
with like a brief overview of kidney
exchange markets and what they actually
do so a little bit background about
activity transplants for most patients
not for many patients that suffer from
kidney failure receiving a transplant is
the preferred F treatment because it
improves their quality of life and also
it reduces their mortality risk also
from the society's perspective receiving
a transplant is actually very
cost-efficient right so we save a lot of
money each time a patient gets off the
early-season actually see it's a chest
so given this it's not surprising and
it's widely known that if you have a
severe shortage of kidneys many people
are waiting many people unfortunately
die while they are waiting for
transplants and the reason is that the
supply of your short in supply so the
supply comes from other humans and
basically comes from donations we have
two types diseased donations and life
donations now kidney exchange is related
to live donations see how that works
if a kid if a patient needs a kidney in
most part of the world except for Iran
he cannot buy a kidney so he needs to
find a loved one to basically donate the
kidney
how many people actually do find someone
but they're that donor that in turn that
order is not biologically compatible
with the patient so they cannot go
through with the transplant no in this
case what one what this pair can do is
to find another pair with a similar
situation but now they are cross
compatible and if this coincidence of
one's actually happens these two pairs
can exchange the kidney of their donors
and you're gonna have to basically happy
patients so that's just the basic idea
behind like a two-way kidney exchange of
course whenever there is need for
exchange markets emerge naturally so
that's what hot butt has happened in the
u.s. in the past 20 years we have
multiple regional programs that each one
works with a subset of hospitals and
transplant centers to basically form
these pools of incompatible patients and
donors and in those pools basically
basically search for exchanges nowadays
about 14% of living donor living
donation actually goes through this
exchange for is doing pretty well in the
US and now many other countries have
also adopted this solution and they have
their own national kidney exchange
programs
right now let's see what happens in a
kidney exchange market you can pretty
much expect it's pretty much what you
would expect pears arrive over time and
they by and large prefer to be matched
as soon as they can
and once a bunch of pears arrive then
you're gonna form like a compatibility
graph so each node is going to be a pair
of patient donor there is a directed
edge between let's say pair 6 and pair 3
if the owner of pair 6 can give to
patient of it now as you can see I have
won a special kind of note here which is
like an altruistic donor so this is a
very generous person who just donate his
kidney without wanting one back all
right and this is extremely helpful
because it can start a chain of
exchanges good so once we have this
compatibility graph a centralized
trainer is going to now make matching
decisions so the centralized planner is
going to find matches basically match
the income that their patients to
compatible donors using short cycles or
checks so in this little example we can
basically clear the market in the
following way so you're gonna have a
two-way here you have a three-way
exchange here and also you have a short
chain segment I noticed that we clean
the market and also we are left with one
extra donor at the end of this segment
now this donor can later donate to
someone else so kind of a better picture
of how this chain advances is something
like that all right so this can go on
for quite a while and the record that we
have is 30 transplants so one altruistic
donor donated his kidney and that
resulted in 30 patients basically
receiving the transplant so it's quite
helpful these non directed donors and
this idea of change is actually quite
impact final person who donate is not
obligated to donate
you know that's a very good question but
usually people do and the way that did
they closed chains is that usually
someone who is waiting for a deceased
allocation becomes urgent and they
actually and that donor has been waiting
for example for a month to donate and
they could not continue that chain so
they basically end the chain by giving
that keep needs work
this to a person who is waiting for
deceased allocations but we don't see
much reneging it's like a very few
percentage
all right good so again this was just
like very quick summary how how can
exchange markets what basically all they
do is they organize for these exchanges
now they are of course very impactful
markets they save lives but they also
know that they are not efficient in the
sense that still patients wait quite a
long time in this markets and one reason
that is thought of to be as the reason
for this inefficiency is the fact that
these markets are thick meaning that
there are not many matching
opportunities so what one a study is
that can be thicken this market and if
you manage to do that does that improve
efficiency now how are we going to
thicken the market we are going to try
two different ideas first one is match
infrequently okay so if I wait between
match runs a bunch of new pairs are
going to arrive I'm gonna have a bigger
pool and maybe in a bigger pool I can
make smarter matching decisions right
seems like a reasonable idea let's see
just like seriously a quick example say
I have this is my market today if I
wanna do a match today I can best I can
do is that kind of break it this time so
let's say I go with this one in that
case if tomorrow appear for arrives who
is now only can do a 2 V 3 then I kind
of made a base but if I waited one extra
day then I could basically clear them so
if there is reason to believe that
thickening the market this way is going
to improve efficiency
so that's one idea same an idea to try
is to just increase participation right
bring more people to this program and
that's gonna make your market thicker
how are we going to increase
participation there are different ideas
and discussions that are going on in
order to make this happen one is the
idea of basically incentivize different
exchange programs to collaborate with
each other and basically merge their
pools so that's one idea
second one is incentivize hospitals
hospitals to fully participate so we do
have evidence that hospitals do not
fully participate then they hide some of
their pairs so maybe we can come up with
some incentive schemes that make them
participate they can match internally
between their hospitals their own pairs
which is fine oh but you want you to
take money out and kind of a last
ambitious idea is to bring compatible
nurse so right now compatible pairs just
match with each other is a direct
donation they don't participate in the
exchange programs but maybe we can bring
them in by promising them let's say a
better match and also a very quick match
so that would be another way of
increasing parts
so this idea is feasible this idea is
also feasible let's see if they are
actually helpful so here's my point line
first idea it's not helpful if you match
infrequently you are not going to
improve efficiency and this is kind of a
robust ERISA
second the idea increasing participation
again it's not clear that's going to
always help always gonna be helpful it's
going to basically depends on the
characteristics and parameters of your
poll now why are we getting this kind of
not counterintuitive results yeah
basically the reasoning behind this
results hinge on the kind of particular
characteristics of the compatibility
structure in particular compatibility
structures are heterogeneous and the
earth spars and these two factors result
in having these behaviors
right now let me show you evidence of
heterogeneity and sparsity so let's
start with heterogeneity so here what
I'm showing you is some biological
measure we don't need to get into the
details of that the way that we're gonna
write this we're gonna read this
histogram is that this gives us a level
of tissue type compatibility which is
one of the main factors in compatibility
of a patient anatolia so as you can see
we have some patients on this side and
those are the ones that are very easy to
match meaning that if you give me a
random donor they are very likely to be
compatible with that we also have lots
of patients on this side and these are
hard to match so they are very unlikely
to actually be compatible with the
random x-axis it's just like some
biological measure that goes from zero
all the way to 100 but the way to write
read it is that if I'm let's say I'd no
idea 9 it means that I have 1% chance of
being matched to a random don't write so
I didn't go to so two observations first
of course there's a great level of
heterogeneity here and this distribution
looks kind of bimodal and the second one
going to Federico's question the
basically the distribution we get is
different from four different programs
so here I'm showing you the histogram
for three different programs these are
kind of the main players in the US and K
or MSA and APD and as you can see there
is quite a bit of variation in the
percentage of hard and easy that each of
these pairs
right now let's see with this kind of
compatibility structure what kind of
graphs are we getting so here's just one
example of a compatibility graph each
circle is just one pair and directed
edges are defined as you would expect as
you can see I have these blue nodes in
the middle that have a lot of incoming
edges so these are the easy to match
pairs and also also I have a sea of
these white nodes that have very few
incoming edges so 1 2 or 0 for many of
them just kind of like an evidence of
sparse and heterogeneous graph
right now with this evidence in mind
what I'm gonna do is that I'm going to
set up a stylized model which basically
captures these features and using our
stylist model now we're going to go back
and study their questions about the
here's our model so we're going to look
at an infinite horizon stochastic model
and in our model there are two types of
pairs hard to match pairs we show them
by age easy to match we show them by
each type arrives with its own arrival
rate and also its corresponding now in
order to capture heart versus easy we
are going to assume pH is much smaller
than so let's take a like example of the
pool dynamics let's say this is your
current pool and a pair arrives it's
going to form an incoming edge with any
of the nodes already in the pool
independently and with the probability
that depends on the type of the
receiving agents so here this design
each pair so we're going to have this
edge with probability P H this is e so
half of it
now these are the outgoing edges from
these new arriving pears we also form
incoming edges in a similar way every
note here independently forms an edge
with product so this is how the pool
actually gets formed and the last piece
of model primitives is that we also have
deep altruistic donors now we're going
to fix our matching policy to be a
myopic policy meaning that every time
someone shows up I'm going to try to
form a match and you're going to look at
two types of matchings bilateral and
chain match and for both types we're
going to break ties in favor of each
pairs and random among within its right
you can find the longest part of your
graph I agree what you really want is
the fewest paths that cover the most
number of what is minimum number of
chains that cover the most why would
that be better than megamax yeah
definitely so once we so like we are of
course to use heuristic here we're not
solving them actually this is a stylized
vorak but India in real what they solve
some versions of a traveling salesman
problem but they use it some heuristics
so it's not like it it's not solved -
exactly
d is the number of altruistic donors
that basically the number of chains you
can pour so like let's say I start with
at time zero I have D altruistic donors
and they're gonna keep running the
chains I'm never ending the chains I'm
gonna make two comments about this
matching policy first one is that you
may ask if chains are wonderful why are
you studying bilateral matching and the
reason is that not every exchange
program is using chains simply because
not every exchange program has access to
altruistic donors so we need to also
understand bilateral matching and the
second comment I wanted to make is that
there are some details in chain matching
in the way that edge segments of chains
are formed I'm not giving it here we'll
discuss it more when we actually get to
the chase
and then in reality it does depend on
both but this measure of PRA it's a
probability when the donor is chosen at
random it gives me some sense of how
hard to match a particular patient is
but in practice if you have if you give
me a donor and a patient I need to check
them biologically to see how to match
does it mean that those in equal chance
that my donor will be met with somebody
else as the donor of an easy to match
yes there are independent right now all
the compatibilities are just patient
which which one is hard for easy it's
just one who needs which ones don't
yes they're good so let's think of this
thing
donors are kind of homogeneous patients
are a heterogeneous so they are hard or
easy but they arrive in pairs
another question about the model
right very good so with this matching
policy their efficiency metrics we are
going to focus on is going to be the
expected waiting time in steady-state
why are we focusing on this in this
market viewer people are indifferent
among compatible all of their compatible
pairs so they just want to be mentioned
they want to be matched as quickly as
possible and the second thing is that
notice I don't have a departure you know
in my model so if you join this this
pool you are gonna be matched so the
only sensible measure is to see how fast
we can actually match right and the one
last thing we are going to look at this
expected waiting time in the limit as pH
goes to zero because that kind of
simplifies some of that so the high
types and low types is in how to arrive
but there is a fixed amount proximation
for letting them run to infinity we
actually checked for the case that you
can have post on arrival of the
altruistic donors but every chain ends
at some point right now me this kind of
theoretical setup again let me reiterate
our goals we want to know how far is the
myopic policy from an optimal policy
that can actually wait before matching
people and also we want to conduct
comparative statics on arrival rates and
that that will tell us what is the
impact of increasing participation
right now before moving on to the
results let me just spend one slide
talking a little bit about that analysis
I guess this has been bothering me a
little bit right when you allow more
arrivals into the system
you're still trying to minimize waiting
time but now for a larger group of
people even if that got worse it might
be better overall depending on what was
happening to those people before you
brought them into the system depends on
what they are doing right now let's say
if I merge two pools they can have
bigger waiting time when the two pools
were separate compared to then I merge
them together so that can happen but
they're not being matched anyway very
good very good yeah that's definitely
true so we need to think about the
outside options so that is captured in
their arrival rates right so that they
both both the ratio of the arrival rates
and also the actual arrival rates are
going to matter very good question there
these are not unbiased samples from
population there are multiple reasons
why there is bias in this topic so first
trick that we use is we use littles law
which allows us to relate the expected
waiting time to the number of pairs in
the pool and that's very helpful because
then we can abstract away from time you
just work with the discrete so we
basically our goal in our analysis is to
try to characterize the pool
distribution
and this of course depends on both the
matching care policy and also the
arrival rates once you're fixing their
matching policy we pretty much have a
self-serving queuing system right why is
it self-serving because every pair is
the customer and the server are paired
together and this is and some of the
related to Gideon's work and these
co-authors and others that have this
very nice line of papers that looks at
what are quite matching gofer servers
the big difference here is that in these
works the graph is fixed here for us the
graph is probably the last point the
main challenge in the analysis is that
because we really wanna model
heterogeneity we need to deal with
two-dimensional Markov chains and
they're quite difficult to work with so
we use all kinds of trick mainly
coupling them with one-dimensional
chains which are easier and also use
some tricks that allows us to compute
the expected pool thighs without
actually knowing the distribution so we
all we can show is that this pool size
is very well concentrated around its
mean without actually
it is let me jump right into the results
the first result says that among all
Markovian matching policies myopic
policy achieves evading time which is or
their Optima
what does that mean it means that it
achieves the same scaling factor because
again these are limits results we are
pushing pH to zero and we're telling you
are saying that myopic policy achieves
an the best scaling possible not
necessarily the best constant but the
best scaling possible so generally
speaking what this says roughly speaking
what this means is that matching without
fading is not harmful to the efficiency
now of course this is based on a really
simplistic stylized model so you may not
believe that this actually hopes in
practice I'll show you some simulation
results from our medical paper which
actually shows that this behavior
actually does hold their practice so
here's one example so in a paper
published in American Journal of
transplantation we use data of 10 years
of data from 3 different exchange
programs we actually simulate this
matching process using the actual
biological factors and we try to kind of
be very faithful to the process in the
sense that we include departure rates
failure rates the actually matching both
using two ways three ways and chains so
all kinds of possibilities and again
pretty much get the same so as you can
see here if we wait longer between
matrons the waiting time just gets more
what about the number of branches
question that's coming up on next slide
so this is one metric average waiting
time in terms of the fraction of matched
pairs we actually get the same results
right
so what is the kind of high-level
intuition behind this Ridge the left one
is the fraction of matched so in reality
we have departures so if we wait between
mansions some people may depart so it
makes sense to look at what fraction of
the pool you're actually magic at the
end of it so this left graph given
so intuition their main reason behind
this is pretty much sparsity let's see
what happens if you actually decide to
wait between to my choice
so the first observation here is that if
you look at your residual graph even
people who are already waiting in your
pool most of them almost all of them are
off type H right these are the guys that
are gonna accumulate in the pool just
because they're hard to match now let's
see what's gonna happen in one match
right so I let's say an e note can
arrive it can form two ways with some
ages then let's say an H guy comes
nothing happens another a pair arrives
forms some more two days now notice that
because of sparsity because this
probability is very low and because we
have so many of these guys the chance
that I get a connected component between
this guy and this guy is actually very
small now if I don't get if this
component and this one are not connected
with each other there's not much smart
matching decisions I can do there's no
augmenting path in a disjoint in a
disjoint in a graph with disjoint
components right and if there is no
connection between this part and this
part there's no point in waiting right
if I wait or not I can do the same thing
which is just which one of the edges at
random from each of the components
but in the simulation about the fraction
matches seem to go down because that's
it that's a good question because if I
wait a long time people are gonna leave
I'm not matching them right and I'm just
waiting so people are gonna start
again the main reasoning behind this is
justice party and before showing you
other results I want to just take a
moment and discuss related work so there
has been quite a bit of activity in this
area this question of weight or not
weight was first studied by older in
2010 he looked at like a model with
deterministic possibilities and he
actually showed for most regimes you
don't wanna wait then in 2013 in our
first paper we arrived at the same
conclusion now for a model with a
stochastic and then subsequently Akbar
put it all under stone at all and more
recently and she'll get all looked at
infinite horizon models different
variations single type multi type the
departure without departure all get the
same result
okay so this is pretty robust if you
have zero one compatibility when you
bring edge weights or preferences then
this results is going to break and you
sure that not waiting is going to be
supportive and the two papers that I
highlighted here are two examples of
settings that actually should
that's a very good question I don't
think that not waiting is actually
probably kind of just count how long
people they then do prioritize based on
that and that's gonna give you like in
terms of the expected they think you can
improve that by breaking ties in a
smarter way
great and the last thing I wanna mention
here is that of course weight versus not
weight is not the only interesting
policy questions many more interesting
questions is all set in very nice papers
and all we have actually done fortunate
to have many of the authors of those
papers good now we know that myopia
policies are almost optimal if you're
happy with them let's say characterized
their waiting time so that we can
conduct comparative statics and by the
way they are very close to what's
happening in practice here in this
theorem we characterize the asymptotic
waiting time and we actually show a
phase transition so in the case that
majority of pairs are of type II we're
gonna get a waiting time which is scales
with a 1 over pH with the constant that
depends on their arrival rates in a
non-trivial me on the other hand if in
the regime that the majority of patients
are of type age we are going to get a
waiting time that scales with pH square
1 over PHS worse which is much larger
with a different constant so using this
now we can conduct comparative statics
we actually show that in the first
regime as we increase lambda H as we
bring more H types to the market the
waiting time goes up even in the second
regime the waiting time goes up up to a
certain point up to some lambda store
and after that it starts going down
for both regimes though we can show if
you bring more pairs they easy to match
one everyone is happier now let's see
all these in just one graph so here I'm
showing you mating time as a function of
lambda edge I'm fixing lambda it would
be 5 lambda H goes from 0 to P as you
can see in the first regime waiting time
increases but it is still tiny compared
to what happens here the waiting time
goes up and at some point when you bring
in more questions what the outside
options as if the outside option was not
be in the registry and just wait without
being a nervous tree you shouldn't count
the waiting time but what if your
outside option is being internally
matched within your hospital or if it's
like not your pool not being merged with
another pool right so this is just like
a comparative static so I'm just saying
that in some way you are increasing in a
lambda H what's gonna happen to the
waiting time right if you want to think
about outside options and stuff you need
to kind of model that and use this
results to understand the impact of math
let's say merging so people who'd be the
very bad outside option inverse with the
sale are you making some assumption
about those times about the outside
option where we calculate let's say
mechanically I can increase lambda H I'm
not saying what happens when I'm
increasing language but like in
expectation what happens to the waiting
so this basically tells us that the
impact of thickening depends on the
current market composition it's not
always beneficial to bring more people
to your body now what's the high level
intuition behind this result so in the
first regime then most pairs are of type
II almost all of the age parents are
going to be matched with the e watts
okay so we're gonna have a to H
bilateral matches as a result of this
basically that's why you get a waiting
time it just case with one over pH also
as you bring more aged pairs there is as
you bring more aged pairs and yes you
are bringing more people to your market
but those peoples are not helping each
other because they'll all want to get
match two they fix the set of e pairs as
also this they kind of exert external
negative externality on each other
waiting time cause now if you move on to
the second regime in that case just
because we don't have enough e e pairs
some of the H pairs need to match each
other right as a result of this we get
this one over P HS square and now we
have two conflicting forces on one hand
if you bring more H pairs they all again
want to get match to the same set of is
so that's kind of a negative effect but
because some of them have to match each
other if you bring more of them there
will be more H to H matching
opportunities and that's going to be
very
so that will give us
I know what's the implication of this
very briefly you can think about merging
two programs there's actually lots of
activities going on in different
countries to merge different programs
especially in the in Europe and if you
have two pools that have kind of similar
composition then you know that both
markets are going to benefit because
it's like pretty much you are just
speeding up the process but if it
happens that two pools have different
compositions then one of the pools can
actually be poor self and this can
happen in it non-trivial pain let me
show you an example let's say you are
merging MSA one of the programs in the
US with an arbitrary pool with a pool
with arbitrary lambda Y and Delta H so
what I'm showing you in this heat map is
the waiting time of MSA after merging -
before so in all these parts NSA
benefits from merging with another pool
however if you are below this border
here then MSA is going to be worse off
after merging with another
just to give you like an hypothetical
example let's say if you merge Emma save
it APD another program in the u.s.
preserving their right ratios and
arrival arrival rates MSA is going to
actually be worse off like just simply
more merge them together I'm not saying
that happens but let's say
hypothetically you just merge them and
there is no differentiation between just
for the bilateral policy that we've been
discussing so far yet if you think about
some priorities that's very close to
yeah you can bring it down I just wanted
to use like a real-world example alright
so again you can say that okay this is
not very surprising because APD has a
worse ratio of H 2 e so it has more H
pair Y so that may result in making MSA
worse but if I may merge MSA with and kr
which is another program in the u.s.
actually now MSA it actually came even
though NK r has a worse ratio of e to H
most composition compared to MSA and the
reason is that NK r is so big compared
to MSA that still is going to help
everything like are you just making up
like the labels for those points or are
those kind of results oh by real you
mean so I am taking the actual arrival
rate and composition of those two pools
right but it's a question I know how
many H pairs on a pers arrived through
let's say n KR last year okay that gives
me
right let's say yes let's say every
there's no blood type issue otherwise
you need to go to individual trying to
understand whether you'll suggest that
if they really were to merge like the
gains would be exactly like you're going
on the side so we just sank I estimate
some parameters I estimate stratum and
actually I am a kind of cheating here
this is a hypothetical example I started
with saying that because MSA uses two
ways but APB N and K are actually made a
match mainly through chest okay so this
did not happen in practice like it's a
hypothetical like that so all I'm trying
the point I'm trying to make is that
when we think about let's say designing
an incentive mechanism we need to think
about the compositions of different now
in the last few minutes let me discuss
our results about chain matching first
as I promised let me tell you how we are
forming chain segments so in our
policies myopic every time a new pair
arrives you try to advance your chain
you try to form a new change the segment
and the way you do it is by local search
one step at a time
breaking times at random and giving each
person is prodigy let's see this is not
an example let's say and UE pair all
right it forms these two edges between
these two guys you break ties at random
for the next one you are going to break
ties in favor of this edge one right now
this is a highly suboptimal can be
highly suboptimal because we are not
looking for a maximal chain but this is
practically very appealing because when
you form chains something may fail in
the middle right so you make a change
you make a match offer it can fail and
then that if you have already optimized
your entire chain you have to redo this
while keeping some part of the segment
ethics
right so doing this local search is
actually very practical you appeal it
and surprisingly be sure that even
though we are being suboptimal
in two ways meaning that the match by
optically and you're forming suboptimal
change segments
again this policy is going to be order
of tea you also characterized the
waiting time for this policy and we do
here the results are not actually
surprising we show that as you bring
more pairs either type age or type II
the waiting time is actually going to go
wait so the last inside I wanna discuss
that comes from our result is basically
the value of chains so I told you at the
beginning that there are markets that do
not use chains because they don't have
entre stick donors some countries
altruistic donation is not permitted so
they are legally limited but other
programs especially within us they don't
run change simply because they don't
have access to ultra-stick donors they
don't manage to attract autistic now we
want to know how much those programs are
gonna basically news or in other in
other words how can they compensate and
not having access to chains by bringing
a lot more a pair so let's say they have
a magical way to doing more repairs how
many more do they need so you're gonna
compare two markets both of them have
the same arrival rate for each pairs
market one matches two chains market two
matches bilateral the question you wanna
answer is that how many more pairs
market who needs to have to achieve a
vetting time which is like at least as
good as market one and actually sure
using our results that the second market
needs many more right so it needs to
increase its arrival of a pairs by the
total number of each person in order to
come I do a true instead of one because
if I have a long cycle everyone needs to
operate chain can be done non
simultaneously right so like because
again because of these people so these
people don't turn out do chains right or
they either cannot attract altruistic
donors okay it is very hard to like
bring people right but this basically
says that if you want to invest that's a
good investment try to attract
so with that let me just summarize we
looked at two ways of thickening the
market first one not not very not was
not helpful and he's actually aligned
with the policy changes that happened in
different programs in the past several
years the second idea which is
increasing participation also the
message here is kind of new ones
it can happen on monotone in fact
depending on there
[Applause]
[Music]
in the graph you have this portion
actually I'm not increasing ease and if
I bring more agents they're not helping
each other right so let's say they think
about like a fixed set of people that
they need to be matched with right I am
bringing more people that are not
connected with each other I'd like in a
bipartite graph we are breaking ties at
random right so if you have more
competition the chance that you are
going to be a chosen at random going to
go to is going to rise
thank you very much
[Applause]